tous éviter un accident nucléaire a
zappé ou ridja voilà la mission des
inspecteurs de l'aiea l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
récemment ces agents ont inspecté le
site ukrainien tenu par les russes ils
viennent de sortir un rapport il a été
présenté au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
à new york bonjour fanny chauffin êtes
sur place que retenir donc de ce rapport
d'inspection
effectivement après tard a pas de pas
prendre de pages très attendu et on en
connaît les premières conclusions les
inspecteurs de l'agencé onusienne
accueilli deux gravement préoccupé par
la situation à la centrale nucléaire
d'abord idiot en ukraine il ajoute que
la situation actuelle est intenable et
qu'elle pourrait augmenter le risque
d'une erreur humaine avec des
conséquences pour la sécurité nucléaire
tous les agents de leïla est donc urgent
de prendre des mesures provisoires il
préconise donc la mise en place d'une
zone de sécurité et de protection autour
de la centrale pour empêcher tout
accident nucléaire une proposition que
le directeur de l'aïe rappelle grotti va
sûrement présentait lors de la réunion
du conseil de sécurité de l'onu qui aura
lieu aujourd'hui à new york à 21h hors
de paris on sait déjà que les états unis
et l'ukraine favorable à la création
d'une zone démilitarisée autour de la
centrale merci pour ce